you know the good news is i've just
assumed we were rolling well now we're
rolling yay jelly all right we're
[ __ ] here talking about mushroom
gummies we're talking about mushroom
gummies and how i was like i'm gonna
take six he was like yeah just take two
and thank you what were you saying about
the type of drugs that you don't mind
carrying i don't mind carrying any drug
that you can ingest
that is like an immediate no problem
it's like the instant solving of the i
don't want to we're getting pulled over
we're stressed out i can solve the
problem
let's everybody just split the pack in
half right and we're [ __ ] we're all
going to be high nobody's going to jail
and we're going to have a wild afternoon
we didn't expect you know what i'm
saying those are the best ones have you
done that where you've eaten drugs
before you got pulled over yes before
the cops even went i never i didn't even
get whipped one time he just followed me
for so long what were you eating i took
some [ __ ] troons oh wow yeah it took
like a [ __ ] whole [ __ ] eighth i
mean a whole [ __ ] quarter i like did
the journey dawg i was just like i was
like
he followed me for like 12 minutes i was
like he's whipping me at any moment dude
i don't want to be caught scrambling
when he does so i just
and this son of a [ __ ] just bangs a
hard left on me like he watched me take
him like haha patty have a good
afternoon [ __ ]
aren't those the best highs though
they're like the best drunks like when
you you you go somewhere and you're like
i'm not going to get drunk tonight and
then you end up yeah i had that this
morning you got drunk this morning yes
at 7 15 this morning you wanna hear this
story yeah best story ever we go get on
our plane this morning our plane leaves
at 7 15 this morning i'm on like two or
three hours of sleep
i am i hate flying you've been a little
sick too i saw i've been a little under
the weather i'm starting to feel better
because i took a steroid pack i sit down
on the plane
and the dude next to me is just cool as
[ __ ] and as soon as i sit down i'm
joking i get on the plane i'm like
you're lucky contestant number one you
get the fat guy next to you today i know
that's what he's thinking right when i'm
standing in the aisle tell me there's
not a plane full of people going please
not me please not me and i'm like
and i'm like you're it buddy i'm your
guy and i sit down next to him
and across from us is a nice couple
they're a gay couple really nice couple
they're cool they're in we're all
engaging we got a little thing going in
this row
and before the plane takes off the
flight attendant's like if i want to
drink this was a long flight
and i was like
yeah i'll tell you guys tequila he's
like well i got the margarita shooter so
it's like you know he pours me a big
nice margarita
i smack it dude next to me smacks of
vodka and soda this is 7 17 this morning
flight's leaving at 7 20. we're drinking
before the door shut on the plane
the two dudes next to them were like
they get hype they're just like well
they're doing it we'll do it so the two
dudes are like [ __ ] bring us to vodka
sodas
you know how most times you would have a
flight attendant who like
his job is kind of party police what's
happening
we had the opposite flight attendant he
was a goddamn bartender he would walk
over be like are we drinking or do i
need to twist an arm here or something
fellas like gassing us up we're like
last week on the job yeah it's like i
did find out he's getting off for like
four days
so he's like brings us another drink now
we've just got to the seat belts off and
i'm two margaritas in
i don't drink vodka i just drink tequila
okay the guy goes i'm like that's
getting me into gesture man he was like
the gay dude sweetest dude on earth goes
oh big papa i got you just follow me do
what you did for me give us a double
vodka throw a splash of soda he won't
even notice it'll calm him stomach down
it'll be the best thing to happen to him
these dudes start getting me [ __ ] up
we smacked like six vodkas this dude was
like giving us last call before we
dropped when we're descending he's like
i can legally give y'all one more what
do you think and everybody's like hooray
at this point we're all blackout drunk
almost the two dudes behind the couple
are drinking with us now there's another
girl behind them that's participating
like the entire front half of the plane
is now getting just wrecked this is
amazing it's up dude i pulled in like
i don't remember anything about getting
to where we're staying at
any of the sequences that happened from
how we got there who drove us we came
and ate a big breakfast and i kind of
got back on my feet i was just sitting
at the hotel
pounding water when i got your text and
i was like i've almost sobered up enough
to go do this podcast well you're here
yeah sounds like a great morning man is
that not the best buzzes though